you
hey youtubers is charlie so the warcraft
movie is coming up in a couple weeks and
they're giving away tons of free loot
they're giving away free copies of the
game a bunch of other stuff depending on
which region you live in so this is
going to be an explainer for where all
the free stuff is dropping this is like
an old-school boss drops guide and you
don't have to worry about rng so here we
go so if you live in the United States
anyone who buys a ticket to see the
movie at a participating regal cinemas
united artists or Edwards theaters will
get a free digital copy of the game if
you're a member of the regal crown club
which is like the the regal theaters
rewards program they also enter you to
win a ticket to blizzcon 2016 you don't
get a free blizzcon ticket you just get
your name thrown in the Hat to win one
but still because they say participating
theaters just make sure the movie
theater that you're buying your tickets
at is participating in the giveaway but
they should be good at any of those
three theater chains I'll put a link in
the description so you can go straight
to that page if you live in Brazil in
order to get that free copy of the game
you have to buy your ticket through
ingresso if you live in australia or new
zealand you have to buy your ticket
through hoyt cinema but you also get a
digital copy of the game so yay free
game Europe is a little more complicated
because there are so many different
theater chains that are participating so
I'll just put a link in the description
but you bet it's basically the same deal
you buy through specific theater chain
so you get a free digital copy of the
game if you live in malaysia you have to
buy through gold screen cinema but it's
the same deal free copy of the game
philippines it's sm cinemas singapore
its capital theater and in thailand it's
at any participating SF cinemas and what
it sounds like is is you take your movie
ticket to the theater then you get the
redemption code then you use that code
to plug into blizzards website and then
you get to download the game they imply
that there's a specific limit on the
number of free games that they're giving
away so I recommend you get your ticket
as soon as possible if you're planning
on going or if you want the free copy of
that game but on top of that Blizzard is
giving away a couple of transmog based
on the movie alliance and horde transmog
all you have to do to get those is log
in between May twenty-fifth in August
first you don't have to buy a movie
ticket they'll just they'll give you
some in-game items that allow you to
transmog your weapons but it's actually
pretty cool I'm not surprised that
blizzards doing
in game tie-in it just seems like a slam
dunk from their standpoint hey we have
this big expansion and a movie coming
out in the same year why don't we give
away some free stuff so be sure to get
your free boss drops if there's any
specific warcraft movie videos that you
guys want me to do just let me know in
the comments i haven't done a lot lately
but the movies coming up so i might do
some more in the next couple weeks but
if you're wondering i think of course
they're going to be doing sequels to the
movie i think a lot of it depends on how
well the first movie does i haven't been
playing recently but i did just buy the
expansion i try to log in every once in
a while to get my seasonal achievements
here's a really cool tour the armory
that they just did
okay that's pretty cool so this is one
of those moments where the reality of
making this movie has to step in on the
games because there's no actual Armory
in the game you get all your weapons
from vendors or from drops there's no
where you go and say oh I'd like to try
this and try that this is poetic license
and it's beautiful I mean some of these
things are fantastically made you look
at this halberd you got the crest of
Stormwind on the head of it and it feels
great what about the armor oh my god
they're all real look at lea shields up
there I have a massive head he's heavy
look at this this is a real thing ah
this is so exciting to me in so many
ways weapons and have done a beautiful
job it's a growth of the game it's
amazing so everybody be sure to get your
free copy of the game you don't worry
about rng I know they're changing the
loot system with the next big patch but
why you guys wait for my next video to
post you can click here for my flash
finale trailer that's airing tomorrow
and you can click here for this week's
Game of Thrones thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight